Hey youtubers it’s Charlie!
This week on Walking Dead we got a deep look
into Abraham’s group including Doctor Mullett
a huge teaser for Washington DC and more ominous
Sanctuary signs.
Candy Bars, Comic Books and Easy Cheese for
everyone.
Quick shout out if you’re finding me for
the first time.
Each week I pick one random subscriber from
the comments on my review videos to give an
Amazon Gift Card too.
I’ll be announcing who that is tomorrow
in my Q&A video.
There will be a link to that at the end of
this video.
So let’s talk about our top 5 WTF moments,
then I’ll do my review and list some of
the biggest questions I had after watching.
Careful for spoilers if you haven’t seen
the episode yet.
Number 5 - Smiley Face Abraham Luckiest Man
in the World.
For people who haven’t read the comic book,
this scene was a crash course in Abraham.
He’s got a plan just like the governor.
But despite all the smiley faced Walker Smashing,
the tone of the moment and Tara’s reaction
were fairly positive.
So I feel like the writers want us to trust
him.
There were a couple moments later in the episode
that raised some red flags, but I’ll mention
them in a sec.
Number 4 - Candy Bars, Comic Books and Crazy
Cheese.
This is all about Michonne and Carl getting
to know each other again.
Michonne has started to open up a lot more
about her past.
And Carl has grown up or tried to grow up
really fast in the last couple of episodes.
It’s a good opportunity for us to get Michonne
backstory.
She’s pacing herself in how much she reveals
but I love the bond she and Carl have.
She’s revealing things to him that she’s
never told anyone.
And Carl opens up about Judith.
They’re best friend like Rick wants, but
I think she also kind of thinks of him as
a little brother.
Their scenes are a welcome aspirin pill to
the stress headache you get from Rick and
Carl yelling at each other.
Number 3 - Who the eff is downstairs.
I got a strong Hunters Vibe but since no one
got thrown on a grill I think they were just
supposed to be random survivors.
Albeit really murdery randoms.
There were enough WTF moments from the house
that I actually separated the most notable
ones.
The first being their arrival and Rick darting
under the bed.
Anyone who has hidden under the bed from someone
understands what it’s like when you see
a pair of feet walk up.
Number 2 - My bed now Jackoff.
I was right there under the bed with Rick.
I actually thought he was going to have to
pinch the guy’s nose shut and kill him in
order to keep from being discovered.
He was still breathing and Jackoff number
1 probably would have straight up killed Rick
if he found out.
Later he actually does kill one of the randoms,
but then the tension was all about him turning.
Which he eventually did.
I liked the twist of Rick being able to use
that to escape with Michonne and Carl.
Number 1 - The fate of the human race depends
on Doctor Mullett.
Abraham teases us that because Eugene might
now what caused the outbreak, potentially
there’s a cure.
This has been one of the biggest ongoing questions
of the comic book and the tv show.
I’ve always thought the virus itself was
a red herring, something that didn’t really
matter.
I think the real story of walking dead is
what happens to these regular people after.
And making it about a ‘cure’ would completely
change the show.
Everyone’s focus would be about the solution
and this is really supposed to be a drama
about people.
Now it’s your turn.
Let me know what you’re biggest WTF Moment
was from the episode and do you think the
show should ever reveal a cure?
Overall I loved the deep look at Abraham’s
group, the tease of Washington DC, Rick’s
game of hide and seek and the continuing sanctuary
teasers.
I’m going to give the episode a solid B
plus, just because of all the new elements
that abraham’s group introduced to the story
and the hide and seek pacing.
Things would go from super intense like Rick
staring into that guy’s eyes underneath
the bed and then they’re just easy breezy
easy cheesing their way down the rail road
tracks.
I love the dynamic of Rick’s group now that
Michonne is with them.
It just gives the writers opportunities for
more comedy and have those classic family
breakfast moments.
Rick and Carl might be doing better, but I
still see a lot of tension between them.
Most of that now is over them thinking baby
Judith is dead.
Here are a couple of important questions I
had during the episode.
1 - Is the Crook road sign meant to imply
that Abraham is a Crook?
2 - Does Carl’s character genuinely hate
soy milk or were the writers just trolling?
3 - When are they going to run into Baby Judith
again?
Quick Side Note though.
Both Tyreese’s group and Rick’s group
are headed toward the sanctuary, they’ll
probably all get there before the end of the
season.
4 - What was up with that mutilated painting?
Was it just meant to juxtapose the nice looking
one of the Rabbits?
I actually thought the Rabbit painting was
a visual mirror to Lizzie killing the rabbits
in episode 10.
5 - Is Eugene Autistic or just really clumsy.
Despite looking like a redneck, I’m totally
willing to believe he’s a real deal scientist
who can help.
But the whole clumsy rifle scene kind of says
DO NOT trust anything you hear about this
man.
and 6 - What is Abraham trying to atone for.
Tara calls him out on the DC mission.
I think it’s pretty clear he did something
during Iraq or Afghanistan that he wants to
balance out.
Let’s try to answer all those questions
in the comments.
It’s going to be a little while before the
show gives us explicit answers.
Next week is Daryl and Beth and from the looks
of the teaser things are only getting worse
for them.
Remember I’m selecting one random subscriber
from the comments to give this week’s gift
card to.
I’ll announce who it is in my Q&A video
tomorrow.
Right now click here to get last week’s
episode and click here for that Q&A video.
Thanks for watching, see you guys tomorrow.
High Fives!